Chelsea Loeb uses a responsive neurostimulator
implanted in her brain to help prevent seizures
essentially making her a real bionic woman.
And a $200 million dollar plant in Maryland
is being built to create energy out of chicken
poop.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
A new study shows that babies learn faster
from surprises.
When presented with an object that defied
their expectations, babies not only paid more
attention to it, but also created and tested
hypotheses around their confusion.
For example, when a ball appeared to roll
through a wall they tested its solidity by
slamming it against the table.
Showing babies use what they know about the
world to motivate learning.
And the researchers are trying to understand
how much knowledge humans are born with and
how much is from a result of our observations
of the world.
A new 3D printer can form soft objects using
fabric.
Utilizing sheets of off-the-shelf fabric layers
are bonded with a heat-sensitive adhesive
and the contour is shaped with a laser cutter.
It can even include conductive fabric to sense
touch as well as a fabric coil for wireless
power reception - for a soft cell phone case.
1,962 feet below the Gulf Of Mexico researchers
from EVNautilus had a rare encounter with
a Sperm Whale.
The remotely operated vehicle piqued the interest
of the whale and hearing the researchers reactions
is just great.
Oh, wow.
Gorgeous.
Holy cow.
I think we beat the other watch today.
Oh man.
This is so neat.
*laughter* Wow!
NASA recently unveiled their Modular Robotic
Vehicle.
The MRV is a fully electric car with autonomous
and remote control featuring four independent
wheel modules capable of steering 180 degrees.
It has a top speed of 40 MPH and they claim
the sideways driving is like driving on ice
but in complete control.
Aside from Moon and Mars driving, applications
could be manifest in retirement communities
or taxi services.
Parkinson’s diagnosis may be possible by
typing on a keyboard.
Current diagnosis happens about 5-10 years
after the onset of the disease but by analyzing
the subtleties in people’s keystrokes we
can learn a great deal about psychomotor performance.
Researcher noticed a huge difference between
people typing wide awake and typing after
being woken up in the middle of the night.
And they hope to develop a way to use this
kind of data for early detection of Parkinson’s.
Meanwhile, General Atomics is building the
world’s largest superconducting electromagnet.
The 1,000-ton ITER Central Solenoid will be
used to drive a hot plasma for fusion energy.
It will be among the most powerful magnets
ever built with six modules housing the energy
of 1,000 cars going 100 mph.
The international nuclear fusion research
megaproject is a collaboration between 35
nations to demonstrate the viability of fusion
energy.
Finally, researchers at Pacific Northwest
National Laboratory view a battery under a
special microscope to see why a battery loses
strength over time.
Each discharge of the battery leaves behind
lithium metal.
In this trapped state, the dead lithium can't
contribute to a future charge.
You can also see the electrode cracking from
stress.
I’m gonna leave you with a pack planter
robot transplanting rows of pansies.
And as always - thanks for watching!
Hey so uh...Vsauce has been nominated for
a Webby for Science & Education.
So go vote!
You only have a few days so just do it now
probably yeah.
Vote now vote.
Vote.
Now vote.
Vote now.
Now Vote.
Vote.